à l'attention des occidentaux le message
c'est clairement celui de la menace
qui est fait pour le peuple russe et de
l'autre le discours qui est fait à
l'intention des Occidentaux à
l'attention des occidentaux le message
c'est clairement celui de la menace
on va tenter le rapport de force et on
va vraiment tenter de dire l'adversaire
voilà jusqu'où je peux aller au gros
mais déjà un la menace nucléaire était
déjà utilisée dans le passé dans
d'autres interventions et surtout ce qui
est intéressant c'est qu'on voit
certaines formulations qui sont un peu
étranges comme de dire ce n'est pas du
bluff si en général et un peu la vie de
faiblesse dans une posture de
négociation que ce soit Vladimir Poutine
son ministre de la Défense ou les médias
russes on a passé un certain nombre de
temps à parler de la menace du
funnucléaire de devoir repréciser qu'il
s'agit pas de bluff Satan a essayé de
redonner un petit peu de force à cet
argument qui avait perdu du sens en gros
c'est un peu comme la personne qui
créole tout le temps à force de dire
qu'on peut utiliser l'arme nucléaire on
finit par croire qu'on utilisera jamais
ce qui est intéressant dans la partie
qui vise le peuple russe c'est que d'une
part on retrouve tous les poncs de la
rhétorique de justification c'est-à-dire
on ne fait pas la guerre on ne fait que
se défendre l'Ukraine n'existe pas et en
plus on met une bière juste il faut
diriger
on voit bien que il y a cette
dialectique très étrange qui consiste à
dire à un moment donné tout se passe
selon les plans qui ont été prévus par
le ministère de la défense c'est que
quand Vladimir Poutine doit prendre la
décision qui réellement doit être très
impopulaire qui est d'une mobilisation
même partielle il ne dit pas j'ai
décrété la mobilisation partielle mais
une formulation encore plus étrange
venant d'un autocrate j'ai décidé de
soutenir la décision du ministère de la
Défense d'autoriser la mobilisation
partielle c'est comme si Vladimir
Poutine par anticipation peut-être ça
c'est l'avenir qui nous lira tente de se
déresponsabiliser de cette décision
radio
justification qui est en train de
s'installer si on voit plusieurs
éléments qui tiennent à la fois de du
logo et du pathos sur logos il y a
vraiment la volonté d'apporter des faits
qui ne sont d'ailleurs pas facilement
vérifiables sur le fait que l'OTAN tente
de menacer la Russie en langageant des
manœuvres unitaires en commençant des
missions de reconnaissance si tout ça
est un peu douteux mais d'un point de
vue de pathos vis-à-vis du peuple russe
il y a aussi notre justification qui
tient déjà à expliquer que des exactions
seraient commises par ce qui continue
d'appeler les néonazis en place à Kiev
et aussi ce qui est intéressant d'un
point de vue historique c'est
d'expliquer que les territoires qui sont
acquis font partie historique de la
novolatia c'est-à-dire de la nouvelle
Russie qui est une terre qui au final a
toujours appartené la Russie donc là ce
qui peut être inquiétant dans l'absolu
même si on peut toujours se dire que
c'est quand même ce qui existe depuis le
début c'est une position de négociation
et surtout de bluffs vis-à-vis de
l'Occident ça consiste en dire tout ça
difficultés à toujours fait partie de là
aussi donc s'opposer à au fait de
reprendre des territoires qui ont
toujours été à nous c'est menacé de nous
faire la guerre et si vous nous faites
la guerre vous savez très bien qu'elle
sera la conséquence ultime